hi my name is gabriella vixen this is my
cover of rihanna by young bane and this
is for standout TV
[Music]
can I say that I want in you I'm in love
with the way you move and think we
should have a drink
Oh - truth is I wanna lie with your son
on my way you feel like you need
somebody so baby just come my way feel
like you need somebody Diplo watching me
dip low doses on me and now he sips
though watching your head down to your
tiptoes you know I got something for
when you get home get home now you're in
my zone in my soul and we gonna get gone
wouldn't you Framus like windows Zarafa
come and speak and get those give me a
love I know you're bad ivory and up I do
you good know what I love cuz I can
promise forever
oh no you make eleven oh you're bad like
Rihanna I do you good
no wahala cuz I can promise forever no
I'd say that I want in you I'm in love
with the way you move and I think we
should have a drink
Oh - truth is I wanna live with you so
come my way feel like I need somebody so
baby just
my way for Maggie needs somebody cuz I
can give you what you need but oh oh so
tell me what you want from me now so
tell me what you want from me none
you're looking my way now show love when
we lay down I want some now and some
later give me a reason why you can't
stay round oh you make it look easy you
know that you need me you know that you
made me I said you make it love you know
you're bad like we Anna I'll do good no
cuz I can promise forever oh give me
love you Anna
I'll do you good no why cuz I can't
promise forever oh no cuz I can give you
what you need now Oh cuz I can give you
what you need now so tell me what you
want from me
yes I can give you what you need now
[Music]